[ __ ] we're gonna watch not a no actually
apparently yesterday the Russo brothers
did a watch along on a revenger sang
game being one year since his release
Collider New Avengers endgame
behind-the-scenes videos and photos
revealed by the Russo brothers that I'm
only assuming was put up during Twitter
so I thought it'd be fun to react this
little assembly here to see what is in
store for us let's get to it I'm going
to skip the article I'm sure it's a
wonderfully typed article but I just
want to get to the good stuff guys so
here we are
okay alright this was brie Larson's
first day ever as Captain Marvel here's
a quick video of heard reading the cast
for the first time after this day she
would forever be loved by everyone
worldwide especially all the men in the
world yeah let's see here oh of course
she hugs the woman first Wow Wow
Chris ever just waiting to get that hug
you know wow what a great tease that
some great contacts we got there Russo
brothers really insightful oh we've got
some Russo family cameos here that's
Joe's daughter Leah oh I didn't know
that aunts son Julian her nephew Augie
what Oh Lia love the memes of heard Abby
when this first came maybe love is a
strong word Avengers Assemble
there's no audio again Oh
I
ah they gotta be really excited to be
mark ruffalo animagic in the make in
here
kids love Mark Ruffalo does anyone
actually have new masters 69 handle on
for tonight Avengers oh my god that's
what Mark Ruffalo water yeah that is the
series imagination the guy had pulled if
there wasn't a new master 69 before
endgame there is one now our insanely
talented crew transferred a street in
downtown Atlanta and to Tokyo for this
oh wow they shot that Tokyo scene in
Atlanta no say that she / to do that
whole thing in Atlanta yeah they get a
tax break so they were just got yeah
yeah
oh that's very impressive
this should've just CGI didn't like
everything else there's some BTS from
Joe's iPhone walking through class on
the shots of hot guys time-travel
journey oh man there was a Russo
brothers should create a patreon page
yeah you just put out their phone videos
against so many here we are getting
ready to shoot a scar scene the stately
Cathedral and Durham we had to wait for
the choir rehearsal to finish
they shot this at an actual feature they
build Tokyo in Atlanta they shoot this
at an actual Cathedral by the location
hopping around must have been a total
[ __ ] rebuilding a set from preexisting
movie is pretty damn cool also getting
Hana the same amazing cast year after
year is also pretty damn cool Avengers
is sample look at them ah no Joss Whedon
in sight who knows though maybe
Fantastic Four nothing can accurately
describe the overwhelming sense of awe
you get working on working with Robert
Redford the first time Joe's daughter
Ava eight years old met Robert sure as I
said you're that guy from the sting
movie
oh wow she she had a really wide palette
for an eight-year-old yeah absolutely
went all the way back to the sting yeah
oh she's a big fan sneakers look how
cool Robert Downey jr. is in that photo
it's just too cool for school Oh mo what
the [ __ ] is this this was a very
difficult scene for Karen Gillan she had
to land a platform six feet in the air
with her head tilted up for six at four
hours a very cool in love with him I
mean let's face it all the Scots are
cool here's a model of the set what
scene is this when they take her apart
and she's all you know expanded out of
oh because it's in that yeah it's like
if you go further into that hallway
there it looks like that room is that
how she developed her body for Jumanji
mm-hmm just all that planking for six
hours were workers here we are working
with her at cousin Rene Russo
yeah JK she's not our cousin she's our
sister
oh that Arrested Development humor is
that shotgun it looks like Shawn gun I
feel like I was right he was he does the
body for rocket that's right yeah BTS
atony cabin at man in New York
you do this and it doesn't work
ladies are doing their really the final
scene I don't know I don't know if they
I was like is it a wrap for the day or
is it a wrap for the entire fit makes me
wonder yes I'd be a random Xena shoot at
the very end this is from Chris Evans
last day of playing Captain America Oh
Oh much learn respect to you sir what an
amazing run I love that he didn't want
to he didn't want to take off the mask
oh he wore his home he was saying bye to
everyone while we're i keeping the suit
on and the mask on - ah his last time
wearing it that is America's ass the
Grand Wizard of fortnight helps defeat
Thanos Donald mustard and Laura muster
joined us on the set for the final
battle dude
Oh sweetie changing lives for deny game
yeah it made it everywhere this is
called an element shoot poor van
physical effects right there yeah
physical effects are fun it's just
feeling like a very meditative reaction
video put you into the cinema process
but it's also very fly on the wall
Downey's last day on set after shooting
the I am Iron Man moment the very
definition of the legend we loved this
man three down
[Applause]
what it must be like to hug Robert
Downey jr. see he's not that old
I love how like goofy Chris Evans can be
Sharon endgame for the first time last
year with each and every one of you was
the most thrilling or a morning or
moment our careers thank you we eagerly
await the day that we can all be back
together in a theater sharing these
experiences once again oh wow oh dude to
be in the theaters with the Russo
brothers the first like for first time
for them being with a crowd oh I can
imagine what that must have been like
for them oh dude they must have been
weeping but it's ready to make the most
money in the world
[Applause]
Wow god I'm being their shoes and to be
with that Crowder we like we've we did
it I'm getting that emotion flush again
what a splash page now
that is such a great seat if an abyss
like taught me yes oh it's right there
do you like yeah yeah you just feel like
you're in a litter in a weird way this
is what I went to the bathroom brothers
were watching with the crowd at the time
Missy that was the point where the ester
came in was like sir you can't be
recording it right now it's legal it's
law that was absolutely beautiful
see it makes me wonder what if we don't
go back to the movies the same way and
this is the last big a million billion
trillion dollars movie that we all got
to see together come on Pete we're gonna
kick the coronavirus right in the ass
you're going down [ __ ] virus you're
going down stand a chance yeah you know
what I loved about this was this wasn't
a professional photographer on set this
was just their own phone recording
footage or maybe stuff that was airdrop
to them from other people who worked on
the movie this felt very raw this wasn't
at all like promo clips that you're
seeing assemble for some special
behind-the-scenes stuff this is the kind
of like home video footage I made that
joke about they should start a patreon
page you really feel like this behind
the scenes footage at the Russo brothers
released feels from the the lens of the
Russo brothers like just their own
personal heart sharing that with it with
the crowds and such such a beautiful
thing yes this is so funny to think
about how when infinity war came out
they were asked for the longest time
when's Avengers 4 coming out what's the
title of the next Avengers movie where's
the ones the trailer they were kind of
getting like harassed to a certain point
where they even did a Collider Q&A they
got on the megaphone just saying they
won't talk about like they're not going
to talk about it that amount of
anticipation and that
mount of poking at them to have this
movie come out and it's a year later and
revisiting this moments from the
theaters on this little tiny phone with
like terrible quality put me back in the
end the experience of the first two
times I saw this film with a crowd that
was just bananas the whole time and with
Angier telling every line to me right
before they said it yes he loves to
predict stuff and whisper it into my
inner an important plot points I'm like
I know he's going to say assemble you
don't have to say it said
Avengers and okay for three hours and
[Laughter]
resources messin with you buddy I know
you're probably watching so honestly I
would love to see more behind the scenes
things in this vein that are just little
fragments that are sort of told from the
perspective of the filmmakers and the
emotional experience of making it as
well as the technical cuz I mean there
are some really great behind-the-scenes
features on a lot of you know movies and
stuff but I think one pitfall of some of
them as they get they're telling you
sort of what you know if you watch the
movie sure and this was insightful in a
different way it just sort of gave you
that fly-on-the-wall experience and I
think a lot of people would probably
have loved to have had and yeah
especially even in just a small way to
watch you know Chris Evans and Robert
Downey jr. have their last you know
moment on set you know embracing
everybody like it's moving to see in a
way because it does remind you of like
how much of a community and how big of a
assembly a movie has you know and how
much family is kind of bonded through
that if you have a good set anyway yeah
alright guys vendors hang game does it
still hold up for you do you still love
the movie leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that ohta fication bail
check out our endgame review or there's
a sketch on there last but not least
patron of the day shout out
I wanted to shout out our friend Matt
beer he's been a longtime patronage act
longtime follower of the channel he
supported the movie trivia Schmo down as
well he actually came on the channel
quite a long time ago randomly visited
California he came on he's a really
sweet kind gentle human being dropped
him off at the subway station never to
see him again
but you can still catch him on his
YouTube channel
TMG entertainment they recently did a
live stream that was all going to
charity purposes the guy is seriously
just an amazing amazing amazing human
being he's someone who is constantly
either sarcastic or doing something
incredibly generous you fluctuate
sometimes one of the cute and I love him
for that and I love him for the amount
of knowledge he's up constantly
providing and for how much of a
caretaker and a gentleman he is thank
you Matt for being you and TMG
entertainment go subscribe to the
channel there's a link in the
description box thank you guys